people have always loved collecting
sports cards and now
the nft is offering a digitized way of
doing that for the future
an nft is a non-fungible token which
is a unique individual digital asset
that can be traded sold done whatever
you want with it's kind of taken to
popularity as being used as forms of art
or music
but particularly it's grabbed hold in
the sports world as a substitute for
the sports card which has been rising in
popularity um making a resurgence over
the last few years
dapper was founded in 2018
uh they're a blockchain company that
creates
non-fungible tokens non-fungible tokens
unlike cryptocurrency every single one
of them is
different or at least rare because
basketball cards are
two-dimensional uh motionless
and kind of old-fashioned they wanted to
capitalize on what blockchain would let
them do
and they're doing these things called
moments nba
top shot is dapper labs
project in partnership with the nba
to create these moments each one
is unique or rare just like a basketball
card is unique or rare
and they've proved wildly popular
in the same way that when i was a kid i
used to trade my basketball cards with
my friends
people online are trading these nba top
shot moments with each other
topshop basically takes the best parts
of trading cards and makes them digital
the nba is well known for kind of being
forward thinking and
tech savvy and all of these things and
um and that's
that's they've really shown uh how what
can happen when they lean in because
you know these are really these are
really the most important assets to the
nba right they're the highlights or the
most exciting
moments of the game topshot actually
makes money by collecting a
transactional fee
on anytime something's bought and sold
and that kind of gets divvied up a few
ways uh dapper labs obviously takes a
cut the nba takes a cut and the nba
players association
takes a cut to be honest
when i first heard of it i thought it
was dumb it didn't make sense
i didn't understand why people would pay
for something that's not a tangible
product
but you know as times went on i've
started to research more about nfts and
learn more
and you know the way our world is really
shifting towards digitalized items
um it made a lot of sense for me the
more i learned about nfts and and
blockchain and how there was a limit to
how
many of of certain item could be created
and that's what gives it you know its
value and things like that so
uh now i'm really intrigued in it i'm
learning more about it every day
when i got a baseball card basketball
card or a pokemon card
because i used to have those um i wanted
the holographic one i won the limited
edition one or all other stuff all we're
doing is
adding a digital signature to to that
space and now these these cards and
things instead of
carrying around a booklet you know
because i had a booklet of pokemon cards
when
when i was a kid now i can i can keep my
collection on my phone and
they can have uh you know different
actions or or
gifs or highlights or whatever it is
attached to them that make them a little
bit more
um alive capturing the nft market
capturing the scarcity doing things
that are fun for fans is always great in
the entertainment industry
the the fan is the true lifeblood and
the source right like you have to have
the talent but if the fan doesn't want
to
you know purchase that experience then
there's no money flowing into the
systems
the business problem that nba top shot
solves is it lets the nba be part of the
nba
fan economy um forever because um
as these cards are a there's a
marketplace where all trading happens
it's completely transparent
um and then as uh the secondary market
grows and evolves
uh the mba actually has a direct
interest in that because they get
a revenue share from the transaction
fees
that happen on the peer-to-peer
marketplace until recently um
nba top shot was largely funded
with an 11 million dollar capital raise
with some interesting investors
adapter labs has managed to make that 11
million dollars go really far
in fact a recent number put their total
sales at
430 million dollars in the short time
since they launched
however that's nothing compared to what
we're going to see
they announced a 305 million dollar
investment from some big name tech
investors
but perhaps more importantly from
basketball players like michael jordan
whose well-known branding presence is
going to be a huge boon to the company
this puts the three-year-old company
at roughly a two billion dollar
valuation
now this is perhaps not too unheard of
in traditional tech spaces
but for the for blockchain companies
that have taken
years to get to the billion dollar range
the fact that dapper labs is
already in excess of two billion dollars
shows exactly
how big the interest in nfts has become
i would though say that the winners will
be the ones that
can have a robust ecosystem economy and
marketplace behind it i think that's
what dapper does well
right like and what they'll continue to
do uh well like the more you can create
a community and economy and ecosystem
around these nifty so they have
uh utility they have training pairs they
have you know just fluidity
um and they're not just like uh you know
stock uh um ill-liquid
assets um the the better that
the nft market will be long-term it's
pretty crazy what's going on we saw
lebron james moment go for over two
hundred thousand dollars last month
and top shot itself is approaching
around 500 million in total transactions
yeah i mean honestly top shot is uh
something we talk about a lot
in the locker room um you know
specifically guys that are involved
you know i just think the digitalized
aspect really is intriguing for people
some people are looking at is they want
to do something different they won't
want to
continue to do what their parents and
people have done before them they want
to find
new ways you know be innovative in their
own ways yeah i think everybody's
warming up to it
i think uh nfts uh especially with it
being nba top shot right it becomes a
low-hanging fruit in terms of uh
the educational process for my peers
because they're
they're seeing right nba so it's just
kind of the logical leap
uh isn't too far there's an elephant in
the room here and it's
it's whether top shot and
rising nft prices are a bubble you know
the true price of anything is just what
someone's willing to pay so what happens
when people are no longer willing to pay
for the things that are so highly priced
you know we've seen almost a decade of
bitcoin now and the lessons we've
learned from that
is that speculation can drive it high
but ultimately something that has
utility and something that
has a purpose in society will find its
way eventually
i think it's important to think of this
as just
a proof case for a new technology
the ability to trade rare assets
and importantly to store them safely to
custody them
this is really similar to what amazon
did with the warehouses
and i think that once these companies
prove their product
once they show that you can safely store
hundreds of millions of dollars worth of
value in a distributed network
like a blockchain you're going to see
them expand into
all kinds of digital assets
you